pull out trash taste [ __ ] again and see
uh who's going
to pick joey sure okay next is corner
wow we literally did this again yeah we
went in order last time i'll put these
two back in
yeah all right pull mine up put it up
all right check this
out all right i'm i'm ready for a lot of
toxic gaming right here
i'm ready for a lot of pro gaming i have
reasons behind all my picks here
okay and also i think some of them
you'll be like yeah someone be like what
the [ __ ] wrong with you
all right here we go check this [ __ ] out
check the [ __ ]
okay check this [ __ ] out some good guys
okay there's some here that i was like
all right fully expecting yeah
fully expected some of them okay i'm
gonna have to give you points for uh
the middle three there yeah bro
especially the very middle one i was
not expecting from you super mario
strikers is like if you played that game
as a kid you know you're in the middle
it is
so good it is legit like it is an actual
crime fifa oh no that ain't got [ __ ]
yeah god was here being pro at fifa i
was here [ __ ] clapping my friend's
cheeks with the super smashes
bro super mario strike is right if
you've played this game you'll know
exactly why this is on here
this [ __ ] is god tier like everyone
who's played this game [ __ ] loves it
the original gamecube one right it's
yeah yeah yeah it's
so good and it's an actual crime we
don't have this on sweden have you
that it was that one and also sloggers
as well the baseball one
so oh my god oh my god you hit me with
the nostalgia
super mario sluggers gamecube is so good
i had a [ __ ] ordeal
trying to get sluggers on the wii oh
really really um so
what happened with was is that what i
saw sluggers somewhere
online i was like mom i want this and it
was only available from like
taobao or something on china right like
so my mom bought it from china
right for me for christmas and it was
like the one game that i really wanted
that christmas
and i put it in and then obviously the
wii has um
that that has a what's it uh regional oh
the region log yeah so i played it and i
was like why isn't it working mom and
obviously my parents have no [ __ ]
idea
is that like what is it we bought you
the game it's the game why isn't it
working i mean
they they didn't figure it out either
and so they sent it back and bought
another one
from china again because for some reason
it didn't it wasn't out in europe for
some reason oh really i think if it
hadn't released yet because you know
back then it was like for some reason
they would leave six months between yeah
the release and uh
europe and australia were always the
last ones together yeah yeah because
you'd have to see all these youtube
videos you're like i know this exists
why can't i buy it and so
i had no whole ordeal i never got to
play it in the end even though oh really
two or three times i played sliders at
my friend's place and i had
the most fun i've ever played in the
mario spin-off game i think yeah what is
sluggers there's the baseball baseball
one yeah i think that
the mario strikers is the best mario
spinoff game striker there's the
strikers they're sluggers and then
there's uh
mario three on three basketball as well
oh my god yes do you know that one
i never played that but dude legit i
feel i feel like you're just
naming mario party mini games dude
honestly all of the sports
spin-offs of mario are all such [ __ ]
solid games
like mario tennis [ __ ] solo mario
golf [ __ ] solid i think i legit would
put like strikers like
like up there with mario kart like main
line yeah i would i think it's that good
like
like to me it's like yeah okay of course
i like sunshine gone
yeah but like
mario strikers that's when you're woke
you're like i'm listening
like if your mates like you wanna play
strikers you're like [ __ ] yet yeah
cause it was always like you know are
they you know cause there was this
mechanic and it was probably the funnest
mechanic in a mario game where like yeah
you so your team would be made of two
main mario characters so you'd have like
you could put like waluigi and then
you'd have like four coopers or
four uh birdos or whatever right yeah
and then he could pick like wario
and so there's this mechanic where you
could choose to do a super shot with the
main character if they had the ball
and it was basically like a quick time
event and you just nail it in like the
perfect like
the the like the be like an arm that
would swing and
hit it in the perfect zone if you got it
perfect it would be a guaranteed goal
so it's always a thing of like holy [ __ ]
can he do it and it was so hard
because the timing is super fast so it's
it's [ __ ] tiny and you have to
i think it's not even guaranteed unless
you're past the halfway point right
we passed the halfway point to do it and
yeah it's it's [ __ ] it's so good
it's so [ __ ] good dude but do you
want to go through your three by three
sure
sure so okay okay i gotta ask first i
know which one you're gonna ask why
what the [ __ ] is battalion wars okay all
right i've never i've
never heard of it i've heard of it i've
never even heard of it if you look up
battalion wars it's like
one of the highest rated games on like
the at least this one is on the wii
and the first one is one of the highest
rated games dude it is like a really
[ __ ] good strategy game all right so
so it's like um so i really like the
online where it's kind of like
um that's pretty hard tricks like tanks
no
so it was basically like you'd be given
like a set amount of army so you'd be
given maybe like three tanks
four long range tanks ten uh ground
units and there would be a mission
and so the the way that it worked is
that you would have to try and
take over or take over a base or push
push the enemy out
without losing as many people as
possible but the online was really good
because it was essentially
the same thing but one person was
defending a point and the other person
had a push
right and it was really fun because i
got really [ __ ] good at it when i was
like
15 and i would just keep winning and i
would like cheese people with strats and
stuff it's such a good game
i played so [ __ ] much of that game
it's so good because i've never heard of
this game right
and i look at this cover and i'm just
like this looks like some chinese
knockoff game
you can see you can see the cover here
right now oh dude it's good
dude it's so good check out gameplay
okay probably
i'm just i'm not because i'm just like
genuinely curious why i've never heard
of this game before yeah
it's kind of like um i don't know how to
explain because it's like
it plays somewhat similar to halo wars
but but quite different like oh that's
it as well
so i completely forgot one of the main
mechanics of the game so imagine a
real-time strategy where you can be like
give me conf first person control of
this guy yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] get on
the ground and do the work yeah
so you can swap between the units of who
you're doing first person right so
because sometimes obviously the
automation is like good yeah you can
obviously be way more like in control
and do more damage so like the
like you know because there's tanks
there's planes there's whatever like the
planes were okay but if you went first
person you could really [ __ ] [ __ ]
people up with that yeah and you could
dodge [ __ ] way easier and stuff like
that
dude it's so good anyone who played
battalion wars 2 will know it no no no
i'm not i'm not laughing i'm just
realizing that we went through my entire
three by three
talked about it for an hour and not once
did i use the term mechanic
that's all gameplay mechanic i'm just
like oh yeah
i guess gamepl all of my nine is that
like i really think they have like
super re like strong game mechanics no
no no i i look at this and i'm just like
yeah
a lot of these have really strong
gameplay loops like guitar hero [ __ ] of
course